this is
let's see
thank you
good afternoon everyone uh this week
month we are opening with a prayer uh
provided by Suzanne Bruce who came and
saw me earlier today
father we thank you for your presence
with us here today we are reminded a new
word to be humble and gentle patient and
to bear with one another in love we ask
for your wisdom and guidance as we meet
together in unity today may your
blessing be upon us as we ask that as we
seek to serve you in all that we do in
Jesus name amen please be seated
ah
now just some uh safety precautions as
we had during the meeting uh which had
the protests and since we have a full
house here today uh if there are any
major disturbances I will stand up which
will require Silence from everyone in
the chamber and that will be the first
and final warning uh if I am to stand up
again then counselors will also be
standing and exiting until the major
disturbance has
been dealt with is that clear
fantastic
welcome everyone welcome counselors and
media here again today to our council
meeting uh apologies I've not received
any apologies are there any apologies
around the table
note looks like everyone's here
conflicts of interest do we have any
conflict of interest for any of the
items on the agenda today
no confirmation of minutes so first up
is the confirmation of the minutes of
the extraordinary meeting of the
District Council on Tuesday 16th of May
did I have any questions or comments
from counselors on these minutes
it doesn't look like it could I please
have a mover that these minutes are true
and correct counts the guardian and
seconded by councilor Stringer
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against motion is carried
minutes of the ordinary meeting held on
Tuesday 16th of May
any questions
ah you worship I just have a correction
please and my statement on page 10 it
says the word
um driver not river
it was the discussions about the Matera
River Crossing
thank you Council
got that Susan
brilliant it's been acknowledged
any other comment
could I please have a mover that bar
that one change that the rest of the
minutes are true and correct
Council Dixon in a secondary councilor
Phillips I will put the motion all those
in favor please say aye
and against
the Motions carried
uh confirmation of minutes of the
ordinary meeting held on Tuesday the
30th of May 2023
do we have any questions or comments on
these minutes
copies have a move that these are true
and correct uh councilor Paul mcfail and
a seconder
councilor Reed
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against the motion is carried
finally we hear the confirmation of the
minutes of the assets and infrastructure
committee meeting on Tuesday the 6th of
June
any comments or changes
uh councilor Phillips
I think you worship just a comment um
and a question just a comment about uh
the leak detection of Matera just a
reminder to Residents that if you've
been contacted
um to
uh
fix your leak as practical or as soon as
practical just to help out with the
ongoing costs involved with making water
and just like to ask if there's any
three Waters perhaps Jason maybe I've
asked this question about how the organ
Street project went on the weekend
crossing the river crossing the railway
line sorry
thank you
so you wish it sounds like a setup um no
just uh good news to report there that
everything went through uh smoothly on
the weekend in terms of that project so
that was uh um you know a good result
um and certainly the weather played ball
When contractors got through that
critical piece of work so no
thank you counselor and thank you Jason
and well done to the team on that
soil councilor guidelines handy you
happy to set there's a true and correct
move that is true and correct and
councilor McDonald to second that I will
put the motion all those in favor please
say aye
and against the motion is carried
did we have any urgent late business
I have some for the in committee section
um but it is will be with included it
will be included within uh the
uh
uh the power to act delegations and
unbudgeted expenditure item so no need
for a food I just wanted that noted so
the public know there is some more
information there
moving on item number five uh the
petition
so as standing order
17.3 States members may present
petitions on behalf of petitioners which
I will be doing right now in doing so
members must confide themselves to
presenting the petition the petitioner
statement and the number of signatures
uh so I will do that now
um the petition is the GDC CEO Steve
Perry to resign uh the Patricia's
statement uh is there in writing I don't
think I need to read that out loud uh
and the number of signatures is 4858.
uh as our standing orders permit me from
saying any more than that although based
on interpretation I will be sticking to
that I will now open the floor to any
further comments
um I just also wanted to note that
um we'll refrain from staff commenting
on this topic um given given the nature
of it do we have a first commenter uh
councilor Richard mcvale
yes thank you you worship
elected members sold out advice from the
illegal Council last week regarding
their legal obligations surrounding the
upcoming petition
the advice that the council has received
from the illegal counsel is as follows
the employment of the CE is not a public
matter
and the employment relationship is
private it is not a matter for the
public to debate
if there are serious allegations of
wrongdoing then the council as the
employer must act
but beyond that it should ignore
wide-ranging or basis allegations
as stated in the agenda item before us
on the 3rd of May the council resolved
that the mere and Council of support and
have full confidence in the chief
executive and the staff and providing
for the ongoing functioning of the
council
in undertaking its day-to-day activities
and that is still true today
it must be noted that despite all the
media attention and public pressure
staff of the gore District Council come
into work every day
and they continue to do an outstanding
job
and this doesn't go unnoticed by the
councilors
and the council
I'm sure all my fellow councilors will
join me in thanking the staff for their
unwavering commitment to this community
I wish to reaffirm that the gore
District Council staff are members of
our community as well and please respect
this
counselors are also aware
of strong support staff have for their
operational leadership of the gore
District Council
thank you wish
thank you councilor
is there any further comment from the
floor councilor Dixon
thank you Worship in terms of the
petition it's actually null and void for
the following reasons petitions need to
be no more than 150 words and this
petition has more than 150 words and
they must not be disrespectful I didn't
agree with the petition being placed on
the agenda at the cheers meeting and I'd
still disagree with it being placed on
the agenda today
I note that my name is on the petition
as well and I can categorically State I
did not sign the petition
the uninformed commentary and
unjustified attacks on the CEOs staff
and counselors is extremely unpleasant
and it's detrimental to the gore
District's reputation the mayor and
councils have stated publicly that they
support the CEO and staff and I believe
the Gould District Council staff are
diligent and fully committed to ensure
the best possible service is provided
for our district we all just want to get
on with our roles without harassment as
it is very hurtful and unjustified
thank you
thank you counselor
any further comments from councilors
councilor hovel
I wish to move the the report be
accepted and that the petition not be
accepted
I will speak to that if there is a
second
councilman actor now seconded moved by
councilor Havel seeking my counselor
make dinner
we've got to ask the first question what
have we actually received
we've received some comments made on
Facebook
where a number of people have agreed
with it it's no different than something
appearing on Facebook and getting a
whole lot of likes
but what actually are they liking the
statement that comes with it refers to
the CEO it refers to councilors it
refers to the underperformance of the
press
a lot of people actually support him
a petition needs to have certainty as to
one who is it addressed to and what is
the action that the people are seeking
with regard to who it is directed to is
it intended for something to be
submitted to the chief executive to take
into account is it something to be
submitted to the council asking them to
take action that is not specified
you can infer all sorts of things in
terms of what's there but it fails to
meet the test of what is required by a
petition
petition is also contrary to Natural
Justice
with any petition it is necessary to be
able to verify the names of the people
who have supposedly signed it
we have no email addresses whereby we
can identify whose names are on that
list we have multiple people who have
signed it on on different occasions and
multiple the same names appear on
multiple occasions
for example someone I know that lives in
gore shows up as an interesting
invercargill someone who says they live
in in Gore as well is a postcode for
Christchurch
the number of blank spots in it just
names cartoon names the chief
executive's names on it
the what has been submitted to us has
little and no credibility
the since the petition was launched at
the same time we embarked on approval of
some terms of reference
for looking at the issues that are
facing us here at Council that includes
looking at the culture of council and
therefore the petition actually takes us
no further ahead from where the council
sits at present
the Facebook link or the Facebook page
refers to bullying and as noted by
Council Richard mcphail the staff here
are the ones who are also suffering from
The Bullying I've heard stories of
people who are being insulted in the
public Council staff who have been spat
at at meetings and it's totally
unacceptable
I say to the staff Like Richard I'm
extremely sorry for what the collective
actions of the elected officials have
resulted in over recent months you don't
deserve it you have our full support and
I applaud you for being an awesome team
that are carrying on keeping this
Council undertaking its business as
usual thank you
foreign
thank you councilor
councilor Reed
thank you Mr Mia
some of the questions that I did have
asked have been referred to in the legal
letter so and I'm just going to make a
statement in my opinion the petition has
no legal standing or validity and it's
very malicious in its intent
it is in direct legal immoral conflict
with our obligations as a good employer
to the chief executive
the mayor and councilors have committed
publicly to work together to rebuild
Trust
to working as a team and start beginning
with having full confidence in Mr Perry
and the senior leadership team we should
not compromise that by accepting the
petition I believe if we did that it
would be showing extremely poor judgment
potentially exposing rate payers to
further costs
and I would also like to acknowledge as
the previous councilors before me the
stress that this has caused to our chief
executive his family and the staff and
their families of the gore District
they have continued to do their jobs
professionally in the face of nasty
vitriolic and personal attacks
and I thank them personally
thank you councilors any further comment
from the floor
no we have a motion on the table which
was that the report be received and that
the council does not receive the
petition and notes well it does not
receive the petition
any further discussion
yeah uh yep
I will put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
and against
like to be recorded against thank you
the motion is carried
item 7 former Gore Library building
did the oh sorry no we have uh Emergency
Management cell phone first
so I skipped the page uh welcome to Mr
Simon map who is the group manager for
Emergency Management Southland
and we're doing a presentation for us
here today
when you ready Simon welcome
yeah thank you Mr Mayor and thank you
councilors for receiving me today
um I'm just here just to talk through
Emergency Management Southland and
um and the expectations of elected
representatives before during and after
an event
um I'm I guess that's my uh PowerPoint
there
um I've got no
thank you
you might need it fully ice cream
so just as this comes up on screen
Emergency Management Southland is a
shared service between the four councils
in Southland
and we represent all four councils
um we're based at environment Southland
and we have an emergency coordination
Center there and there is a manager five
full-time staff and one part-time staff
and the Emergency Management Southland
also runs the AFA project so that's the
Alpine fault project which is magnitude
8.
I would just carry on yeah
so behind basically from a national
perspective what we aim to do is
identify resilient communities
we're away right so we we aim to
identify uh resilient communities from a
national perspective and as you can see
there those communities increa include
lifelines utilities central government
um our emergency service partners and
City District and Regional councils and
above all communities
the um the Emergency Management
Southland approach to emergencies is to
actually prepare our communities first
as you can see these plans for the gore
for the Croydon Lodge and from matawada
in in the fact that we meet with the
communities we talk about preparation
and we've got a number of initiatives
that we carry on to ensure that people
are more prepared obviously the more
prepared the community can be the less
pressure in the time of a response to
the welfare uh the welfare needs of that
area however we are there to assist uh
when when needed
so the Emergency Management Act is our
overarching
legislation and as you can see there it
promotes that sustainable management of
Hazards encourages communities to
achieve acceptable levels of risk
provides for planning and preparation
and encourage coordination across a wide
range of agencies
so how we work is we have the group
sitting down the bottom there the
Emergency Management Group EMS as we're
called and we have a lifelines committee
and Emergency Services Coordination
Committee lifelines are things like
telecommunications power
etc etc
all the things that provide
life lifelines to the communities
the emergency Service Coordination
Committee is made up of fens St John's
police and Emergency Management and we
meet
um every two months above that we have
the operational subcommittee where we
meet tier twos from all four councils
and they provide mentorship for the EMS
staff and guide us in Direction and
financial matters we have the welfare
coordination Group which is a group that
meets with all the welfare agencies and
ensures that everybody is ready for a
response at any stage and the Readiness
and response subcommittee which is a
committee that ensures that we are ready
to go at a moment's notice we then move
up to a coordination executive group or
The Keg is it snowing
um The Keg is the representative of the
CES of all four councils and then lastly
The Joint commit sorry keg also includes
the emergency services
and Doc the heads of those particular
areas and then we have our governance
with our joint committee which is the
Mayors and chairs
of of the councils
so the role of elected members
as you know as elective elected members
uh you know your community is better
than most and the role for the elective
Representatives is to know us ensure
that we uh we don't meet for the first
time at a response and to take an
interest an interest in the Emergency
Management developments that we're doing
um I have these books uh a number of
these books here for you to pick up
afterwards there's a number of things
during an emergency as elective
Representatives uh we will call upon the
mayor and the deputy mayor to assist us
at the ECC but so the emergency
coordination center before elected
representatives we'd love you to be
within the community in those Community
hubs uh talking to people and making
sure that we get the information from
those Community hubs
obviously dispelling rumors and
information and validating issues is a
really important time sorry a really
important subject especially in this
time of social media and how things can
kind of grow legs
um and considering recovery issues from
the uh from the word go
um afterwards we're talking about
um listening to our communities and
um ensuring that uh
we're Gathering um the views and
concerns from the community if it's a
major event we're going to be looking at
how we recover from that and how we go
back to business as usual for the
community and how we improve or look to
more resilient Community after an event
lastly we have a booklet here and I've
bought some of these in as well these
are the what would you do booklet and
they basically just ask questions about
if you were stuck at home Etc one of the
things we do require elected officials
and Council staff to do if possible is
be as prepared as possible as they can
possibly be before a response as you can
understand in a response we're going to
need a lot of people out with the
community as soon as possible and it's
impossible to do that effectively unless
you know home is looked after so we ask
you to be prepared as possible before
that
a couple of other initiatives that we've
got at the moment is we have a lifestyle
block emergency preparedness handbook
that will be um uh setting out on the
30th of June after the joint committee
and that goes along with the make a plan
uh book as well
so
um
that's my presentation I'm happy to take
any questions
to be of any question thank you very
much for that Simon that was that was
fantastic did we have any questions for
Simon from the floor
uh councilor Reed thank you Mr weird I'm
just wondering Simon like when the big
one hits in fieldland which it will and
probably not too far into the distant
future what would be the effects of that
by the time it gets down to gore
uh thank you and through you Mr Mayor
um the effects are going to be it well
it's hard to judge because none of the
experts um can say for 100 sure of
what's going to happen from the modeling
that has been done and I'm talking about
the Alpine fault here
um most of Gore and uh and the rest of
Southland has less shaking than uh than
other areas within the South Island
obviously the West coasters
um is going to Bear the major brunt of
that and I believe the fault line goes
through the middle of France Joseph so
there's going to be some real concerns
there as far as Gore goes I believe the
the seismic action we'll be getting down
here
um fingers crossed will not be as severe
but I can't really tell you exactly what
that will result in whether it will mean
that we have
um damage to roads or infrastructure Etc
um
the IFA program though is um uh a
program about preparing for that and we
have a set of response planning groups
that meet with lifelines utilities
um it also has an insights and Intel and
a welfare coordination group where these
groups get together and we start talking
about how we will respond uh respond
when the Alpine fault actually does
happen
and I guess from another just another
perspective that you have
um people who will be in Milford Sound
and places like that
um
what are the plans for that going
forward is that part of this initiative
because obviously that's going to take a
lot of it'll only be air flights or
helicopter flights in and out for people
who are hurt
yes thank you and through you Mr Mr
Mayor um that is correct there is there
is a number of risks associated with the
Alpine fault um and especially isolated
areas like Milford
um are going to be doubly affected by
their isolation we're working very
closely with the the tourism groups
within Milford and also the whole
Milford community so we have a fjordland
hazards working group and we do tabletop
exercises just to explore where we've
got fragilities within that Network
again though it is isolated and if we
didn't have the Alpine fault we wouldn't
have Milford so it's yeah there's
there's a positive with the negative I
guess
yeah
thank you councilor and thank you for
that song any further questions
councilor Phillips
thank you worship it's not much a
question it's just um
just a uh might as well take the
opportunity to promote my Terror once
again while I'm sitting here talking to
you Simon just a reminder to Residents
tomorrow night about our meeting with
sort of with um
roads to management tomorrow night with
all the residents of Matera
um if anyone's watching online we'll see
you tomorrow night
thank you councilor great reminder
any further questions
I just had one other one for you Simon
you mentioned at the mayor and Deputy
mirror would assist in the ECC
um just for clarification obviously that
ECC is is typically an invercargill if
there's a flooding event in both well
along the mataura river would it be
expected that the the mayor and Deputy
assistant invercargill or a localized
one here in here in gorse that we can be
with our community
uh thank you Mr Mayor
um what what happened in the 2020 floods
as I believe in IMT was run from the
gore District Council and therefore we
wouldn't require somebody to travel to
invercargill that declaration can be
done either online or over the phone
um we certainly will be bringing staff
into the gore District to assist with
that particular event
thank you for that Simon
any further questions
no we will move on thank you councils
and thank you very much for that
presentation Simon
moving on item number seven former Gore
Library building did the Arts and
Heritage Creator or all the chief
executive want to speak to this report
uh thank you worship the report I think
is fairly self-explanatory it details
the history of the library at details
the history of the development of
Precinct
it outlines the issues that the previous
Library faced in that um in that
building it also outlines the three
proposals that were tabled
over a three-year period in 2017 to 2020
which outlined a variety of options the
option vary considerably some were
fairly basic
roof replacement others explored almost
a complete rebuild so there's enormous
variances there
and um obviously the council is not in
the position to be able to address that
uh at the moment but it's an incredibly
useful space for us and you will realize
that with the um development of the
model I Center but also the refit of the
wind Hamilton Wing which is our
collection store and District archive
there's an enormous amount of work to do
and we have both projects have been
challenged given the incredible
increases in basic building costs
but not insurmountable
we have been working very
closely and carefully with the options
of recycling and repurposing and instead
of the off-the-shelf components that one
would normally expect for a museum fit
out we have been looking at various
options all concurrent with fundraising
um so to that end the former Library
building is incredibly useful it's
currently full of
um
pre-used items and that's items to
shelving for storage but also items of
of display Furniture we would ideally
like the use of the building for at
least 18 months to work through what we
can we preface for the fittier for the
middleweiss center we also suggest that
the it's a good opportunity to start
scoping the possible future use of that
building
and we're suggesting that it be a wider
discussion than just inside Council
Council obviously as a partner but the
precinct has been developed with
Partnerships with various funders and
organizations and individuals and I
think there would be enough Goodwill in
the community to assist us
with some options that could be
proceeded to council maybe an 18 months
time
unless there's any questions I
um who just suggested that the report be
received
and hoping for a favorable response from
Council for the use of the building at
least until 2025 in its present state
but our team obviously undertaking
maintenance that's required from time to
time
thank you for that Jim do we have any
questions uh councilor mcphail
do you worship um
I thought the building's Burger to be
quite Frank but obviously it's not
um I got major concerns over this
building
um the survey we had a couple of years
ago
um we're in 60 of the public said they
wanted it knocked down now
we've got to listen to people and and go
back to the community see what they want
to do with it what is the cost to the
community going to be I don't want any
further cost on that to the community
because we've got enough things on their
plate now as it is
um
that's one thing can we sell a building
we've got to look at that is it valuable
to sell does somebody else in the
community want it because they can have
it as far as I'm concern but
um that's one of the things we need to
look at
um but the survey is a key thing we've
got to listen to people if they don't
want it used for the council purposes
we've got to look at that and honor that
so that's all I need to say
think of their counselor councilor Havel
the council is currently progressing its
long-term plan which puts in place at
sprinting intention for the next 10
years
um I think of staff are wanting to
commit the council or request us to have
a look at funding for something over the
18-year period it probably needs to
happen in the next six months I'm not
comfortable with waiting 18 months and
trying to make some decisions and and
very the long-term plan at that stage
I'm fully supporting of a cultural
center in that part of town but for me
the bottom line is what is reasonable to
afford and that's something we'll need
to look at as part of the long-term plan
thank you councilors as we seem to be
doing statements rather than questions
I'll allow the statements across the
board Council Reed I'm thinking I just
wonder if Mr Perry would mind commenting
on the reason why the option to demolish
was in that original
survey please yeah through your worship
my Recollections the Auditors wanted
that as a as an option
um and I think the feedback at the time
was that the other proposed users were
not that well defined and people really
didn't know what they were they were
perhaps what they were voting for and
the Council of the day decided to
perhaps not perhaps to go away and do
some further work to actually parade
some more serious options in the next
iteration of the ltp which of course is
now just 12 months away so that's why
we're here today
and absolutely to given that the
building is been a problem child from
day one and you know councilman fails
comments about knocking the building
over it could well come to that but I
think the whole thing behaves us to have
a serious look at what are the costs of
rectification versus demolition is there
a reasonable use
um and and I think strategically no
matter what feature what the future that
building is is how would any alternative
use fit within the overall what is now
regardless and Arts and Heritage preset
so those those more I think concerned
measures we need to take in the the ltp
2024 and Beyond is the perfect forum for
which to do that and to engage the
community in the process
I think it's their counselor I think
that Steve uh Council McKinsey
through your worship I would like to
concur with Paul councilor mcphail
um we don't have any money to spend on
things
I think can it be sold and I totally get
the fact that Jim may need it for until
2025 for storage until your Project's
completed fine by me but we really do
need to I think look at
can somebody purchase it and let them
sort the problems can we do that that
would be I don't want to see Council
spending a cent on something
unnecessarily
this is my comment thank you
thank you councilor
any further
comments uh councilor McDonald's
yeah with our current debt levels the
council certainly can't entertain
spending money on this building until we
reduce our debt level we even I reckon
at least by 20 to 25 million be to get
it back within reasonable control so
selling it would possibly be a possible
option if we could find a
people that would be interested that
would also fit within the in the
precinct
then I'm in favor of like Council
mcphail McKenzie said of actually
putting the building up for sale and the
country music people did express some
interest in the building at some stage
so if we could get a sale even if it was
a mental amount and they fix it up that
would help the council thank you thank
you councilor just because we're talking
about costs I actually did have a
question of probably best for Neil
there's a conversation in the
uh that Jim just alluded to and also in
the report that there's continuous
maintenance and staff visits regularly
how much is that um estimated to be
costing the council currently to perform
those that that maintenance and checks
uh through the situation is that it has
been checked regularly
just for any leakage most of the problem
with the old library which is with the
black mold and asbestos has been removed
quite some time ago
so this is a safe environment now and a
lot of the actual construction issue was
related to the roof area
with constant which is regular gutter
cleaning
there's really no ongoing issue with
um
water getting into the building
except when we did have the recent
downpours that a lot of places did with
more leaves than anything so
with Jim and his staff there
I have not needed to be checking and
they're using it as a general storage
and work area which is quite suitable
for that so apart from security
alarm system in fire alarm there is no
ongoing cost to maintenance back
as I say from regular gather cleaning
which all buildings within the core
District are being done
so
I would stand and support that Jim
continues using it as a storage shed
otherwise
um
there is going to be an ongoing cost for
having to store a lot of lead equipment
somewhere else
like yeah
okay oh yeah sorry cancel Stringer
oh thank you worship I just wanted in if
it has to be militaril we have to vote
on saying that we allow them to occupy
the building for 18 months for that for
that term is there anything along those
lines that we have to do
uh thank you Council I don't believe so
it's a council line building so how
Council decide to use councilman
building is is up to the operational
side
um
what I'm what I'm picking up is As a
couple of themes here one is that it
needs to be a discussion for the
long-term plan
and the other is around the survey and
potentially the need for a new survey
that talks about whether the community
would like us to sell it whether they
would like us to demolish it or whether
they would like us to continue to build
upon the precinct that's there and that
might be able to be done either as part
of the consultation process with the
long-term plan or maybe it might be
worth getting ahead of the ball and
doing it separate so that it can be part
of the discussions in the long term plan
I'm not sure but that that's kind of the
themes that I'm picking up here
councilor Phillips did you want to thank
you
well I've listened to everybody just
about
and everyone knows my position about
this building
and I made it quite clear when I was a
counselor that when there were money for
the roof was removed to put into the new
building next door I said at the time
that I would not accept any more money
from the go to set Council budget to be
spent on the old library
why did we move
you know for I'm not against it for for
sale and the sooner we can sell it the
better it may be and if it can take a
percent off our rates to get back to the
right part of them so be it but I
believe that we should not spend any
more money
of Council budget and money which we
haven't really got on the building
that's it exists and I think we should
sell it
would you like to well is there any
further comment but also would you like
to move a motion
in relation to that
no I think you Bishop that we have to
have a a general discussion about the
reason why we want to sell it the
reasoning why if the building is still
capable to be sold at a fair price Etc
what the what the use may be the council
may have a another use for it but I'm
saying as a ratepayer and I'm speaking
on behalf of of everybody in the
district that can we afford to put more
rates on the people after we've just
given them 11.7 rate rise
and I think that we have to have a big a
big discussion about this
and and I think it whether we come
forward with a
a workshop or whether it comes back to
council for the next meeting as a report
and then we can make a a consensus
decision lien I feel
should sorry should this just not go to
the long-term plan discussions in those
different aspects that we need to think
about can be discussed properly
the thinking Council thank you both
councilors I I think it's what I'm
trying to get a read of the rumors
whether we want to report to come to the
next council meeting with uh what what
sale would look like for the building or
whether it's more that we know that it
will be part of discussions in the long
term plan and that's why I was asking
whether whether you'd like to move a
recommendation on the lines of that we
have a report coming back to the next
council meeting surrounding a sale of
the building
I I have it I have a concern about
the ongoing costs
to the council about the upkeep of the
building
we shouldn't be putting money into that
building we should just get rid of the
building
simple as that and I'll probably move
that we have a a formal discussion at a
workshop
uh
for the future use of that building
would there be an ltp Workshop or a
separate Workshop
18 months down the track no it has to be
a separate Workshop
sorry as part of our you know because we
have our long-term long-term plan
discussions yeah the first one for a
long-term plan it should must be make
sure that it's on that agenda for the
long term for the next long-term plan
Workshop cool you happy to move that so
that the sale that it was a report
probably the best way to do it a report
come to that Workshop yeah yeah I think
the if the workshop is just purely about
a proposed sale or it is about the
future of the library building where it
could it could involve potential sale
potential demolition or a potential
third party even improving it and
leasing it back for a use or whatever
all those things are in the mix and then
we will put a report the sale option is
uh off the top of my head possible but
there will be some obligations that we
need to squared away at any event we'll
put that in a report about what those
obligations are for example the land is
subject to
a potential treaty settlement claim in
other words that's the finished writer
refusal that type of thing so that would
be need to be respected in fact into the
decision-making process
yeah
thank you for that Steve and we're
comfortable whether being a workshop
rather than a report and a because it
would be a closed door Workshop rather
than a than out in public that's the
difference between it being on a meeting
item rather than Workshop comfortable
with it so we have that robust
discussion and then bring it to
I'll look front cool happy with that
Council Dixon oh you worship I was just
going to comment that there will be an
opportunity for the public to have input
when it goes into the long-term planes
100 yeah yeah and and well well no to
counselor
do we have a secondary for that motion
uh councilor Paul mcfail
any further discussion on the topic did
we need clarification on the motion
Susan sorry
or have you got it there you do have it
there you okay yep the councils are all
happy
fantastic I will put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
aye and against the motion is carried
thank you counselors
uh appointment of the appointments
committee for the connected joint
committee uh did Rick see you there did
you want to
talk to this
oh
hold on Rex we can't hear you
probably the first one that's happened
but
there we go
um just a clarification
um a project that has come through to
just transitions Regional project or
program
and it's the first stage of
transitioning to a joint committee which
is of course says ultimately I think
will transition through to a um through
to another organizational type so this
is really just the start of that process
the recommendations are pretty
straightforward in terms of
the adoption of terms of reference for
the appointment committee noting in
terms of reference for that overall
joint committee and then if you do adopt
those terms of reference uh pulling a
couple of councils to be on that
appointments committee to progress the
approach with Theology councils of very
large three question States
thank you Rex any questions from the
floor
councilor Dixon
think you worship I'm just um what I'm
wondering is
what
um
what advantage is this for the gore
District Council because we seem to have
a lot of these different groups being
set up and this is just another one
where we have to put resources into or
time and counselors have to go to
another meeting
foreign
so it talks about the report engagement
took place uh region-wide near 22 for
this additional project proposal
delivered to the ministry of business
Innovation deployment in August and then
refined proposed and delivered in
February 2023 I wasn't recruiting for
those conversations but I understand
obviously it's as a result of that
Regional approach councilor Dixon that
was moved it through the mural forum and
the seats at the Mill Forum has has
asked us to come back to each of the
respective councils to progress it if if
our calcitudes not to even that's a
decision they can
oh and we lost them
does that answer your Christian
counselor I can elaborate further if you
wish
it does but I just I would like more
information about where this is leading
to and um what advantage it is for
school district there seems to be a lot
of these organizations set up
so for clarification and it's just my
understanding is
um that that is what being part of that
committee will determine is how to use
that funding put towards the connected
murahoku project so it is what that
project looks like
um what the priority is priority areas
of focus will be to build that
resilience through learning skills
building connections Etc so it'll be up
to up to that committee I guess the way
I I looked at it was I think we should
appoint counselors and at least go for
the first you know meeting or two and
see whether we do need input and part of
that Regional approach and then those
members can then come back to council
and say hey we don't think we need
representation here if if they believe
so but we would be missing out on assay
of of how their MB funding gets spent
does that make sense
how much money is DMV putting up for
this and is this sister Humphrey Act
do you know how much Rex I don't know if
it's in the report I can't remember
saying a number
yeah I'm unaware as well but but we
could get back to you on on that
potentially
uh councilor Stringer
yes thank you worship is there oh sorry
are there any
other districts that are already doing
this that we can copy
uh
off the top of my head counselor um the
only District or region that has
experienced us as taranaki when the um
the no-go on deep sea oil exploration
there was a compensation package put by
the government of the day
and it was called like just Transitions
and so this is my understanding is that
just transitions is in response to the
mooted closure of Ty point
and of course
at the moment while it's mooted there
are signs that there are of
resuscitation potentially of that
proposal to close
um I say resuscitation of actually
keeping it open for a longer period so
if you if we're being brutally honest I
mean this could be the subject of
a change of government an election and
the
um enthusiasm to fund transitional
funding for something that may not occur
May dissipate so that's I guess the risk
he's got a way up and then of course you
over top of that as well as
marahuku based
a lot of the commentaries around the
transition the pain that we felt with
invercargill and outlying environments
so that all those factors you put in the
mix
and to further your point Steve as well
if we don't have representation on this
this committee then it will be more
south than an invercargill-centric as we
don't have the representation there I
believe this is one of the few work
streams that has been approved by Envy
so far because it's one of the ones that
needed less funding
councilor McKenzie
I just heard that word three worship I
just heard that word funding mentioned
from where
please all right MB Ministry of business
Innovation and employment it's not
including the school district council no
thank you
do we have any counselors interested on
being a part of
the appointments committee
don't all go at once
uh Council Stringer
through worship what sort of airs and
time commitment are we looking at for
this
is it in the terms of reference Wrecks
for any chance probably looking
quarterly I'd imagine
uh how often will the
uh the councilors have to attend the
appointments committee
just to avoid the Joint Committee itself
once they've done that job then the
appointments committee will cease to
operate because they will have appointed
The Joint Committee
um
I think that's that's the way but where
we're starting to get to but yeah it
will be it would be
that appointments committee's completing
the undertaking its role uh I think it
talks about the report advertising for
Representatives who might be interested
to go on to the committee once that goes
through that process then that
appointments committee would cease to
exist against Australia similar to what
we've just been through with the south
of New Zealand art gallery appointment
of that that talk committee as well
okay that simplified instead of yeah
weave up
yeah two or three meetings
yeah three meetings over the course of
18 months yeah
can I make a suggestion as no one's
throwing up their hand
um
and please don't shoot me councilor
Dixon but
um given you are the the chair of
community well-being I thought it might
be fishing and I'm happy to join you uh
on this
if you were happy to
you worship I was actually going to vote
against
The Proposal
okay fair enough
uh so there'll be do we is there a
consensus around the table that we don't
want to appoint anyone to this and we
let invercargill and Southland
make the decisions
uh Council mcfire
it's just really worship I think cam we
do need to have some representation
there there's obviously issues that
could come up
um we'll leave the seat vacant uh we'll
never know so I would suggest that maybe
one of the
um not necessarily
um uh a chairperson of communities but
maybe one of the uh first first term
councilors may want to it's an 18 month
tenure
um three meetings so
for clarification you're not putting up
your hand I'm not putting out my hand
thank you thank you
because their papers there's a rock
going on between councilor mcphail and
Council Stringer here or
who would oh
I can I can retract myself as if two
people want to go on I just think my
what records said we do need
representation on it so we might as well
yeah and for a penny in for a pound
fourth
oh we also have a hand from the
community board chair as well I I sorry
it's really worship I'd like to nominate
uh obviously uh councilor Stringer and
maybe on the alternate because there is
an alternate there uh
councilor mcfail other
both happy with that
so we've got cancer Stringer as uh so
myself and councilor Stringer and
councilor Richard mcfallon is the
alternative
is the alternative
uh do we have any further discussion
around the rest of the recommendations
I love to move those recommendations
uh it's cool so and do we have a
seconder
counselor mcdonell
are you are you okay with that I know
you nominated them but um it's going
into the whole package of regulations
right with that Richard thank you uh any
further discussion
all those in favor please say aye
aye and against
the motion has been carried thank you
councilors
uh number nine audit engagement letter
for the period of 30 June 2023 to June
2025 I'll just let the public exit
before I ask for any comment from lornay
when you're ready lornay
through your worship I'm happy to take
the report as read it's a fairly
standard procedural matter that just
requires to become in front of council
thank you Lorna any questions from the
floor
Council Stringer are you thank you
um your worship um
so Delores is assigned by the auditor
general
um
are there any options to be assigned and
this will follow on to the next item as
well thank you
but through your worship
um traditionally either order New
Zealand or Deloitte appointed as
Auditors are the two firms that over
many years have done all the public
sector audits I am aware that
Ernst young are now
um dipping their toes Untold and they've
got one ordered across along the west
coast
um
the Auditors are much more matchness and
my understanding from talking to
counterparts at other councils Deloitte
are a better option than audit New
Zealand
and with regards to fees the auditor
general sets the fees anyway for both
audit New Zealand and for Deloitte so
they they
review the fees and and set them
thank you Lorna and thank you councilor
any further questions from the floor
could I have a movie that the council
approved the engagement of Deloitte at
its auditor for the next three years on
the basis of the terms and conditions
laid out in the sweater dated 10 May
2023 Council Stringer seconded by
councilor Reed
any further discussion
I'll put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
aye and against the motion is carried
audit fee proposal for the year end
annual report 30 June 2023 uh lornay did
you want to speak to this at all
um through your worship again I'll take
it
um as the report has read I will
highlight that yes there are additional
fees and audit like the rest of the
country are experiencing shortages of
Staff which means they're having to pay
more to get staff on online
um as with every Everybody in the
country we are all experiencing
increased costs there are a number of
items that have have also added to the
increase in audit fees we have some new
activities such as met overage with the
joint venture there there was a new item
that they hadn't budgeted previously and
it is quite a complex accounting
accounting structure for that there is
also new legislation and
um the new water entity with Tao taumata
arawi and there's new compliance
regulations that the Auditors have to
check off as part of the order process
so again that that's sit down by the
office of the auditor general and
there's no wiggle room on not doing
those so they're adding additional costs
for both Council and what were required
to to present and also to our Auditors
and and testing and auditing those and
checking that we are doing what we need
to there's some other Financial
standard changes around statements of
service performance so again this is a
new item that they that they haven't had
on their list as detailed before so
there's some new changes there that they
have to check on and with that the
council adopted one of the new standards
around financial instruments early and
again that's another quite in-depth
complicated piece of legislation that
needs to be cheap so
whilst it's disappointing that the
things have gone up as much as they have
there are there are some really good
reasons for it for myself we'll be
holding into account we have had some
challenges in the past where they've had
quite a turnover of staff I believe I've
worked with over
25 between 25 and 30 Deloitte staff in
three years that I've been with Council
so we are constantly training them we do
push back on fees when they ask for
additional at your end and we will be
making sure that we do everything we can
not to incur additional fees on top of
what they've what they've proposed
[Music]
Thank you Lorne any questions on the
floor
counselor string and then councilor
Garden
uh thank you worship um through to
lornadia thanks for that that's um a
good bit of information back and as I
understand it sounds like a lot of it
has actually been pushed on from central
government then is there any
can we go to and say hey look you've
forced these regulations onto us that we
need to now be audited on how about you
cover some of the bill as well
that's where you worship the there is a
paragraph in the later that does say
that as we can negotiate try and
negotiate with Deloitte the oag and my
experience tend to
favor the Auditors rather than rather
than councils but they they try they do
try and be fair where they can and we
are a small Council and for us you know
almost two hundred thousand dollars is
one percent on air rates we also have an
ltp here coming up which is additional
audit costs as well so you know for a
poor rate payers this is this is a big
burden for a small Council
thank you Lorna cancer got on just just
with the performance of last year of the
Auditors is there a discount for poor
performance
and should that be written in the
contract because last year was a bit of
shambles from the above
through your worship it was more
resourcing than poor performance we
worked really closely with them to try
and get things across the line and the
statutory deadline unfortunately for
them they had staff come on and come off
and move on from the organization so
we we did negotiate down some of the
additional fee that they were trying to
charge and
um and we're successful with with that
we could suggest that there's a clause
but it'd be hard to prove
just looking at the budget so it's
actually jumped up quite a lot on the
budget from last year if there was a
poor performance last year and they
charged Inkster and they've actually
budgeted again for another 25
which is quite a major jump and when
inflation's around eight or even like
air Council we've probably put 11 in
yeah
I think there is some pushback
three worship one point to notice for
the three years prior to this they kept
their their budget low so there was only
there was only between 100 and 106 000
that they kept for three years in those
three years we we well know that that
times have moved
um the chief executive and I can go back
to Deloitte and try and negotiate and
and see how we here we go
councilor Stringer
and through his worship too you'll see
can we look at some sort of penalty
clause for over time
um I've encumbed in a lot of projects
that I work on myself but something to
probably consider
uh three wishes look I I've passed
dealings with the oraces is that
um it's a very much not a Level Playing
Field and that the government
makes the laws the order of General
um is an officer of Parliament and
really answers to all of parliament not
just the government
and over the years there's been quite a
lot of creep and scope with audit work
and we see that now what like the ltp is
a classic example where Auditors are now
getting involved things which my hand
will view as beyond their remit but
that's what they do so for example
they'll comment on the issues that the
council should be parading as key things
that the council should be engaging the
community on and I would have thought
that's The Preserve of elected members
and didn't need to be audited so we
started out with Auditors being of the
ltp's uh certifying about the financials
could be relied upon that the
forecasting was sound and that the
appropriate assumptions have been made
but then I've seen over my time but they
all just get right into the the weeds of
performance measures and are they
accurately or crafted
um and we saw that with three Waters
where they took this out on just one one
anomaly for a weekend call out what
wasn't recorded in sufficient time so
that's a bit of background to the scope
creep we can certainly go back to the
Auditors and say look this is just a a
massive leap for us to cop we're a small
Council
and I I'm personally not convinced that
Mount High Ridge is that complex that it
would justify a kind of a high premium
it's a joint venture although I think
Lorna is another turn they use for it
but it's it's unusual but it's not it's
I would like to call it Innovative
rather than complex
and those are things that obviously
we've infected in the pricing but we're
happy to go back and and do our best but
in my experience they you might get a
little bit but they don't give a lot of
ground
thank you Steve and thank you councilor
any further questions
on this item
can I have a mover that the council
accept the audit fee proposal from
Deloitte and for the 2023 Financial Year
and that the chief executive be
authorized to sign the proposal
uh councilor Reed seconded by
councilor Richard mcfail any further
discussion all those in favor please say
aye
and against the motion is carried oh
against
councilor Garden would you like that
recorded
cute
the real reason being uh the 25 increase
and madai Bridge I think they priced
that at 25
000 for doing that work and any Preston
business wouldn't get a bill for 25 000
for their accounts
thank you councilor as is it necessary
that we need to pass the recommendation
that we would like negotiation with
work well I think you've passed the the
general motion of worship so we can take
on more the symptoms of the meeting and
negotiate delivery negotiate down with
the fee and report back our success
hopefully next meeting thank you
uh moving on to point 11 minutes for the
waste net meeting
to uh councilor hovel like to speak to
this at all
oh thank you
I think that it's clear what's there a
bit happy to answer any questions
thank you councilor uh and I will do the
same um there's only
one change I'd like to make but I don't
believe we were the minute writers on
minute takers on this one but around the
appointment of the
uh chairperson I know that Council Dixon
put up her hand but was the alternative
and I was there so we will just need
that corrected I'm not too sure who to
turn to there but
um
yeah I think it's I think it's an ICC
um so I'm sure we can get in touch with
them just to change that
um
but definitely there was full support
from our Council for Council available
to be the chairperson
do we have any questions from the floor
for either myself or Keith around that
wastelick meeting
pretty straightforward
could I have a move that these minutes
be received
councilor Stringer seconded by councilor
Dixon
all those in favor please say aye
aye and against motion is carried James
coming community center and library
development project update did we have
any further updates much executive uh
through your no not really a path to say
look we obviously it's
it's completed in a physical sense uh
most of the final accounts are now in
um and the forecast final cost Remains
the Same as it was the last few meetings
thanks for that Steve any further
questions or comments from the floor
could I please have a
a mover that the report we received
Council limiter
Council Dixon I will put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
all right and against motion is carried
uh before we head into oh no sorry one
more item uh lighting 13 sport New
Zealand uh rural travel fund meeting
did uh councilman want to speak to that
at all
Mike Mike
i Sport Southland uh that it should be
they actually recommendation once they
get
1420.70 which was the same as what they
were requested the only one we took down
was uh
uh Gore high school rugby because they
had a training
a training in there and we don't pay for
training trips so uh that that's that
corrected I'm happy to move the report
but at the ministry of seas thank you
Council on the second uh councilor
Phillips I will put the motion oh
question sorry Council Phillips I think
you worship just a question
um sure you may may remember or may not
just I support itself on what division
was it
was it ice hockey figure skating it was
ice hockey I'm pretty sure okay
[Music]
thank you councilor were you happy to
second that as well yeah
any further questions
uh
cancer Garden no oh Stuart your mic oh
sorry I will put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
aye and against the motion is carried uh
before we go into exclusion of the
public we'll just take a quick break in
between sessions